- I've got a motorcycle sign
over here.
Clint leads me over to an
original Indian Motocycle sign.
- Is it in pieces?
- Yeah.
But it's all cut into pieces.
So why would
someone cut this up?
A guy used it for--
I bought a roll top
desk, and he used it
for the bottoms of
the drawers so mice
wouldn't get into the drawers.
[sighs]
This is absolutely mint.
Who would cut it up?
So he cut this the
size of the drawer?
Yeah.
No way.
And someone lined the drawers
of the desk with this sign.
Because then it
was worth nothing.
It was metal.
It was something to line a
drawer with or patch a roof
with or fill a hole in a wall.
When would this
sign have been?
This would be late
teens, early '20s.
OK.
They were still calling
them "motocycles."
There's no motorcycle.
So this is the Hendee days,
Hedstrom and Hendee, Indian
in its heyday as far
as I'm concerned.
It's hard enough to find
anything antique motorcycle.
So when you add in
how old this sign
is, how far back this
goes, it's unbelievable
that it still exists.
And it's all pretty much
there except one corner.
So let's see.
And then here's
the little town
that his dealership was in.
All right.
So it is missing
a piece, though.
Well, yeah.
But you've got this
you can use, and you've
got this you can use.
This sign is pristine.
The colors, everything
is brilliant about it--
other than the fact
that someone has chopped
it into a bunch of pieces.
God.
So when you bought
this desk, was it--
I didn't know it was in there.
Oh, I was going to ask you.
Nobody knew it was in there?
- No.
And everybody who
sees it wants it.
I know.
I'm one of those guys, I guess.
Have you ever priced it?
No.
My biggest fear now is
that he's not going to put
a number on this sign at all.
He's not even going to
give me the crazy number.
He's just going to say,
I don't want to sell it.
I really don't
want to sell it,
but I can tell you're
passionate about the sign.
Love the motorcycles.
And I-- I'd want the
selling price to be $1,000.
This sign has so
much going for it
as far as subject matter.
I'm looking beyond the chop job,
and I'm looking at the history
of American motorcycles and
how that makes me feel inside
and how connected I am to it.
Just the fact that the
colors are so vibrant--
it might not have
ever been hung.
The person that cut this
sign up, in a weird way,
saved the sign.
And that is why the
colors are so incredible.
The sign never hung outside
because it was cut up
and lined a drawer.
So you didn't know you were
finding it for me back then.
No, I didn't.
Because I'm going
to do $1,000 on it.
- OK, thanks.
- All right, man.
Thank you very much.
It means a lot to me.
Finally, Clint
comes up with an "I
don't want to sell it"
price that I will pay--
$1,000 for the sign.
That's paying up, but the
fact is that it exists.
Once it comes together
on a piece of wood,
it's going to look brilliant.
Hey, look at that.
Clint is in the position
where a lot of people in this
business want to be-- relaxed,
retired, surrounded by all
of the things that they love.
A guy like me, I dream about
being a guy like Clint.
This is going up front.
He's not a seller.
He's a collector.
So for Clint to be able to
let go of some of these items
today, I think that
was really big.
- Appreciate you, man.
- It's going to be too tough.
Really do.
Love the building.
Fun day.
- You got a great eye.
- Thanks, Clint.
Appreciate it ever so much.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
I sold some things today
that I thought I'd never sell,
but I did.
So I might have seller's
remorse, but I'll get over it.
So I'd have them
back sometimes, yeah.
I might slap their hand a
little more than I did, but--
- Sweet picking, Clint.
- All right.
Thanks.
[howls]
Here's the deal.
We all have our ways
of decompressing.
I know bubble
bath sounds funny.
I've never taken a bath.
What kind of smells
are you talking?
I mean, anything.
It could be lavender,
it could be wildflowers,
it could be the Little Pony.
They don't have any man ones?
They don't have no motor
oil or gasoline-smelling ones.
I can tell you
right now I'm not
buying anything
called a Little Pony
and sticking it in
a bathtub with me.